[Music]
hey you guys i'm back once again doing
another book review on my little tomes
of terror show now actually what i had
originally planned to do for today's
video was i was going to reread house of
leaves which i know i've been promising
since like the beginning of the year
but as it happened because it was
halloween week and i was doing a bunch
of extra movie reviews and stuff like
that i just didn't have time to get all
the way through house of leaves so i'm
going to save that for next week but
then it so happened that
do you guys remember like when i did the
review of sons of abraham
um and i said that turner publishing had
been nice enough to reach out to me and
ask if i'd wanted a copy of that for
review you know like an arc advanced
reader copy and they sent me that and i
reviewed it and then they reached out to
me once again uh and asked me if i would
like a copy of this book that will be
coming out i believe it's coming out in
february of 2022
and uh so they sent me a copy of this as
well and because this is a much shorter
book than house of leaves i was like
okay well i'm gonna do this one instead
um you know just because i kind of feel
like if they go to all the trouble of
sending me a copy um you know i really
want to try and get it read and reviewed
like as quickly as possible i don't
really like to leave people waiting
around you know so i know this book
isn't coming out for several more months
but you know
as i said i was just kind of like glad
to get it read and reviewed um and this
book is called spontaneous human
combustion
by
richard thomas now this is a collection
of short stories and richard thomas uh
he's been around a little while like
i've heard the name and i'm sure i've
probably read some of his stories
because
he's had um like 100 over 150 short
stories published in various anthologies
he's edited some anthologies and he's
also written i believe he's written
three novels um a lot of people
recommend disintegration which actually
does sound really good so i'll probably
get to that one day too and uh this is
actually his fourth
um
short story collection now he has a very
distinctive
writing style it's almost kind of like i
almost want to say that it's sort of
like
it's kind of poetic it has like a
surreal bent to it it almost has a kind
of like like a dark neo noir type of
thing
and a lot of the stories particularly in
this collection come across very much
like
they're almost i don't even know i mean
yes they have there are horror stories
and they have horror aspects to them but
there's all kind of other stuff going on
there it's almost kind of like sci-fi
um some of them have like a dark fantasy
type or like a surrealist kind of bent
to them they remind me very much and
it's interesting because there's
actually a pretty extensive author's
notes um thing at the end where he kind
of like explains uh you know where the
ideas for the stories came from and i
always like when writers do that i like
i've done that in my own short story
collections because i wish more writers
would do that but oh well because i'm
interested in how authors got their
ideas so he actually goes quite a bit
into where he got the ideas for the
stories where they had previously
appeared because i think all the stories
i think there are 14 stories in here and
all of them previously appeared in other
collections some of them were like in
you know best horror of the year and
various other ones so these have all
been published before but now they're
all kind of like uh brought together
like compiled into one work see so he
actually did say that some of his
stories were inspired by
black mirror so if you like black mirror
if you like david lynch if you like
stuff like that um that kind of vibe i
think you'll really really dig this i
mean some of it it's weird because like
the first couple stories like i said his
writing style is very
i don't it's not like run-on sentences
necessarily but it is very
it's very evocative
and and dream-like i could that's a good
word and amorphous i think that's maybe
the word that came that kind of like
came to me when i was reading the first
couple of stories they're very so a lot
of the stories are not like concrete in
the sense that this happens that happens
that happens they're ones that you have
to
they're kind of like atmosphere mood and
you kind of have like stuff happens in
them but you really kind of have to like
pay attention to
what's going on because everything's not
spelled out um like i said i kind of
feel like black mirror is the thing that
a lot that some of these stories like
really reminded me of and like i said he
did say in the end that he really really
liked black mirror and he you know liked
particular uh episodes of that and some
of those like gave him ideas for for
this and like i said interestingly too
one of the stories in here he said was
actually inspired by david lynch's lost
highway so if you like that kind of
stuff if you really like just kind of
like you know concrete abc type horror
then this is probably not for you this
is very like i said it's very
poetically written it's very amorphous
some of the stories like
not really like very few of the stories
give you any easy answers a lot of the
stories are have to do with they kind of
have a sense of bleakness or desolation
to them there's kind of like you know a
lot of them are set like after the end
of the world or after aliens have taken
over or something like that even though
things are not necessarily spelled out
you know very like really clearly but
you still get a sense of what's going on
through
the descriptions i guess so they're very
like atmospheric and uh so yeah and so
like i said if that if you don't like
dig that kind of like surrealist sort of
style then probably you're not gonna
like it but i actually quite i really
really liked this a lot some stories i
liked more than others interestingly and
maybe
maybe this is weird but the story i
liked the best uh in this i think it's
called um
notice tollens i think is what it's
called it was actually the story that
was the most straightforward of all of
them um and he even says in the back
he's like this was like a weird one i
don't usually write in this style
because it's very very straightforward
and uh was kind of like stephen king
like which it kind of was it was almost
kind of like a like twilight zoney type
thing too and you know how much i love
that kind of stuff so i'm not saying i
just particularly like that one because
it was the most straightforward and
easiest to follow out of all the stories
but for whatever reason um that one
really stuck out the most to me it was
not the only one actually there's a lot
of really good ones but in that
particular story it's just basically
about this guy who
every year on halloween him and his
friends all get together for this poker
game
and you know they they kind of like sit
around and get drunk and whatever and
you know they and as and as the night
goes on like the last hand they always
kind of like bet really crazy [ __ ] it's
just like whatever there's like oh you
can have my car you can have this that
and the other thing and they kind of do
it every year and it's super fun but
then this one particular year this guy
named victor shows up
and nobody's quite sure
whose friend he is like whenever people
ask him was like hey like who are you or
who which one of the guys do you know
he kind of tells each of them like a
different guy like oh this other guy
brought me but then he tells that guy
that this other guy brought me so nobody
really knows where he came from
and basically what ends up happening is
that victor and the protagonist of the
story like the guy that's telling us the
story um they get to the end like
everybody else folds and they get to the
end and it's like this massive bet like
the like victor is like you know if you
win like you can have i think it's like
some like 60 000 or something like that
and like his corvette and it's like this
classic corvette all this other kind of
stuff so the protagonist ends up losing
and uh you know and he's already bet
like his minivan and all of this money
that he can't really afford and all this
other [ __ ] so
victor actually gives him
a kind kind of a bargain he says i tell
you what um you don't have to give up
your car you don't have to like lose to
me and everything like that but
what i want you to do you can actually
have my corvette
you can have all the money i don't need
it
but all i want you to do in return is to
take this coin and it's kind of like
this special like gold coin with like a
pyramid and stuff like that on it and he
says on the first of every month
i want you to
flip it 10 times
and if you get ten heads in a row
then i'm gonna ask you to do something
i'm not gonna spoil what it is
but he's like you know
he's like what have you got to lose it's
like how
likely is it that 10 heads will come up
in a row so the guy's kind of like okay
like he doesn't really like the idea
like after the dude tells him like what
he wants him to do if 10 heads does come
up but he's like you know again how
likely is that to happen so he takes the
bargain probably surprised no one uh
that eventually after a long time has
passed uh ten heads do come up in a row
and he has to make good on the bargain
but yeah so i think that was probably i
don't know i was gonna say like i think
that's my favorite story in it it was
for a while until i got to the last
story which is called ring of fire which
is actually more of like a novella it's
pretty long
and it has um like an epilogue as well
and it's kind of it reminded me a lot
it's funny because he was at least i
kind of knew where he was [ __ ] coming
from because i'm reading this story and
i said man this kind of reminds me of
that um that movie moon with sam
rockwell in it and when i was reading
the author's notes at the end he said
that that was one of the moon and
annihilation uh were where he kind of
got the ideas for this so basically what
that story is about is there's a guy
and he's in this kind of concrete bunker
like there's like an apartment like
living quarters but he's working there
and he's supposedly like extracting
these really really valuable minerals
and so his job is basically you know you
go to the drill he takes the minerals
and you have to like separate them out
and weigh them and everything and he
does this every single day and he's not
supposed to leave the compound because
it's supposedly somewhere like on the
arctic waist so it's like freezing cold
outside
and it's almost you you get a sense like
as it goes on
because a lot of these stories like i
said are very
purgatorial that's a good word for them
where it's somebody who's kind of like
trapped in some loop and they can't
remember like how long they've been
there or you know what's going on
outside so this one's very much like
that like this guy is kind of like oh i
had this contract for x amount of days
like i said that's why it reminded me a
lot of moon and uh which is an awesome
movie if you haven't seen it by the way
but uh yeah so this story did remind me
of that and he's just like it's it's a
really boring job and he doesn't see
anybody the only person that he sees is
this woman named rebecca who shows up
every 30 days to you know check on what
he's doing and take his samples and all
that other kind of stuff and it's um
it's weird because it's they start kind
of developing like a friendship and then
sort of a romance but then there's other
stuff going on like sometimes he has
like sometimes there's a spider and like
sometimes there's a pet rabbit and
sometimes and like i said he's he has
like all these memories that he aren't
sure he's not sure if they're like real
memories or if they've been implanted or
how long he's actually been in this
place or if somebody's like watching him
so it's just kind of like it's really
really good it's like a really
compelling
story and then like the more it goes on
the sort of clearer it becomes what
exactly is going on it's almost kind of
like it's almost kind of like he's um
like an experimental like a lab rat type
of thing but like i said i'm not going
to spoil it because i don't really want
to spoil any of the stories in this
because you know this isn't out yet but
because and it won't be out until early
next year so obviously you know most
people will not have been able to read
it other than if they had like an
advanced copy but yeah so so that was is
also like a really great story i think
one of the other ones that stood out a
lot and it's actually pretty short
uh is called from within and again this
is a story where everything is just kind
of done by like implication suggestion
like nothing is spelled out like you
know this happened and so this is what
the world is like now but it just kind
of like throws you into
the atmosphere of or the world and you
just kind of have to like you know find
your way through it so in from within
there's like a man and his son
and clearly uh something really really
bad has happened on earth um apparently
like some kind of weird
aliens like alien overlords have like
taken over and they're like these big
floating kind of creatures
and
they pretty much put all the humans to
work like in mines because there's some
particular mineral like i said that they
need uh to survive so all the humans
just do like this back breaking labor
all day long and um you know
i mean the opening of the story is so
great where just like this person like
comes into this man and sons
apartment or whatever and like just
starts measuring the kid
you know what i mean and like as it goes
on like you know what why they're
measuring the kid what they need it for
and that one actually
i don't is this too much of a spoiler
that one actually kind of has sort of a
happy ending or at least a hopeful
ending most of these do not like i said
um a lot of these are very bleak kind of
desolate sort of stories a lot of them
are
you know people stuck in these kind of
like purgatorial loops uh perhaps of
their own making so it really has this
kind of
and like i said it does have a kind of
like neo-noir type of thing too it's
often called like transgressive fiction
they call it that too but it's just kind
of like this
you know it's it's really hard to
describe like the writing style but
if you know you know um this kind of
reminded me a little i have to say this
reminded me slightly
of if you guys remember like a while
back i reviewed another short story
collection which was wounds by nathan
balangrid and uh this kind of is like
that it's not not like exactly the same
but it's like a similar that's like a
similar sort of genre i guess if you
want to call it that so if you're really
into that book which like i said was
kind of like a surrealist
sort of thing
then you'd probably really really dig
this as well this is the first richard
thomas that i've read um he has like a
lot of like i said he's been in a [ __ ]
ton of short story like uh anthologies
he's done stuff with like uh chuck
palaniak who has a blurb here on the
cover so and also so if you like that
kind of stuff um just kind of weird
fiction in general then probably you
will really really dig this and you know
like i said and i only brought up like
three of the stories in there that stood
out to me the most but there are like
all pretty much all of these are pretty
awesome um those three were my favorite
ones but i mean the first story repent
is also uh pretty great so it's just
it's just a really good
creepy
unsettling
kind of like i said surrealist sort of
uh stories and they all kind of have i
mean they're all different and they all
have like different stories but they all
have kind of like
um similar themes to them so the so the
collection really does hang together
quite well even though the stories i
believe were written over like a
five-year time period uh you know and
appeared in various anthologies and some
of this stuff was written
with specific uh things in mind like uh
there was a couple stories in here that
are kind of
nominally about clowns sort of
um one in particular is about this clown
named crinkles but the reason that he
wrote that was because there was an
another anthology like a multi-author
anthology who
and it was kind of all set in the same
world about this character crinkles the
clown but he went like really strange
with it like really cosmic
um there's also like a couple of sort of
like lovecraftian stories in here one in
particular which is called in his house
which is you know straight up
lovecraftian uh and it's also kind of
written in sort of like an epistolary
style as though it's a letter addressed
to you the reader um and i also quite
liked that one as well but yeah
definitely uh check this out like i said
this is uh it'll be out in february of
2022. i believe you can pre-order it at
the moment on amazon and there's a
couple of um
of kind of big like publishers weekly
and stuff like that have already
reviewed it so like i said they've been
sending out advanced readers copy of
which uh i got one right here like i
said advanced reader's crappy i feel so
special but uh yeah so definitely if you
like i said if you dig black mirror or
like any kind of surrealist neo noir
type fiction then you definitely need to
check this out because this will be
right up your alley so yeah that'll do
it for this tomes of terror and i will
be back on the next one bye